thank you very much thank you president
radiff for inviting us to this very very
special occasion
presidents Prime Ministers excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
the project of the gas interconnected
between Bulgaria and Greece has been on
the table since over 10 years so quite a
while it was launched in 2009
at a time actually when Bulgaria was
hardly hit
by gas prom's decision to stop gas flows
through Ukraine
it took a lot of determination to reach
the goal and we saw the video we heard
your words indeed there needs to be a
lot of passion behind such a project and
today I would really like to thank you
the ICB icgb but I also want to thank
the successive Bulgarian and Greek
government for making it happen a lot of
stamina is necessary a lot of patients
strategic patients I think there were
ups and downs and you made it and indeed
as has been said the European Union has
supported this project from the very
first day on politically but also
financially with around about 250
million euros
I would say today a new era for Bulgaria
and Southeast Europe begins
Bulgaria used to receive 80 percent of
its gas from Russia
that was before Russia decided to launch
an a atrocious war against Ukraine and
an energy war against Europe
this pipeline is a game changer
it's a game changer for Bulgaria and for
Europe's energy security
and it means freedom
it means freedom from dependency on
Russian gas
indeed
the interconnector could cover the
entire gas consumption of Bulgaria and
this is really great news in very
difficult times
both
here in Bulgaria and across Europe
people are feeling the consequences of
Russia's War
but thanks to projects like this
Europe will have enough gas for the
winter
we worked very hard the last month
to get there
the first step was diversification away
from Russian gas towards other reliable
suppliers president Alief I visited you
in July for that purpose our friends
from Norway our friends from the United
States Algeria and many others who
helped us in this critical moment
secondly of course saving savings to the
storage that we are managing together
and we should not forget a third step
that is so important that is the mid and
long term and that is massive investment
in renewable energy wind
energy solar energy hydropower biomass
hydrogen you name it
because we know that this is energy that
is homegrown produced here it produces
jobs here and it makes us independent
from others
Europe has in other words
everything it needs to break free from
our dependency on Russia
it is a matter of political will
and ladies and gentlemen this leads me
to my second remark
we are at a critical juncture once more
the energy crisis is serious I'm deeply
convinced we can handle it we can manage
it but it is serious
and it requires from Europe a common
response
that allows to reduce the energy costs
for families and businesses that is the
aim we have to achieve this
we have already taken important steps
here for example yesterday
we all agreed in the European Union to
limit the exceptional profits made by
some energy companies and to take these
profits to targetly support vulnerable
households and businesses
and more needs to be done we all know
this
but in doing so
this is my message
we need to protect the fundamentals of
our economy and in particular our single
Market this is the strength of the
European Union that's where the wealth
of the European Union does come from the
single Market
without a
European
solution
we seriously risk fragmentation
so it's Paramount
that we preserve a Level Playing Field
for all in the European Union in the
single market and it's Paramount to
avoid distortions of the single Market
so the task ahead of us is very clear
we will do more
to contain the skyrocketing Energy
prices which are weakening our economy
and we have to do it as Europeans
together and jointly
this is what we will discuss in a few
days in park with the European leaders
and I'm very much looking forward to
this I very much liked Yamoto if you
want to go fast go alone
if you want to go far
go jointly with others so let's stand
together and shape our strong and
resilient energy Union thank you very
much
[Applause]